[Musik]
halo hat ihn sofort verließ welt heute
habe ich einen regelsatz für euch und
war diese brut hörnchen also ich hab sie
hier in einem brot köpfchen das hinhören
auf einem hefeteig und ich habe die mit
viel tam besteuert und vor allem finde
ihnen eben hohl und man kann sie füllen
zum beispiel süß oder auch herzhaft -
cool oder und vor allen dingen kann man
die auch mal kurzfristig machen das ist
zwar ein hefeteig
aber da wird mit backpulver zubereitet
daher muss er vorher nicht aufgehen und
man kann ihn zu bereiten und gleich
weiterverarbeiten
das heißt auch eine last minute idee und
wirklich super einfach ich hab dafür
spezielle backformen benutzt aber das
kann man auch ganz gut ohne backform
machen und die variante zeige ich euch
auch ich würde mal sagen ich zeig euch
die fotos gesichtet und einige stücke
für den hefeteig frau 250 milliliter
milch und haben den halben teelöffel
zucker 2 esslöffel warmes wasser einen
teelöffel salz
einzig den bug vor feige und 100
milliliter olivenöl und 100 gramm mehl
und zum bestreichen
das eiweiß und etwa 50 kam sesam wir
zuerst einmal die käfer mit dem zucker
und löst sie mit dem wasser aus
und falls ihr seid etwas mehr zeit um
keinen blitz hefeteig braucht dann
könnte sich auch das macht wohl noch
entlassen und ihr könnt auch weniger
hätte benutzen wenn ihr den hefeteig
gegen viel länger ausgehen dass zum
beispiel am abend forschung zu bereiten
in den kühlschrank stellen
und dann könnt ihr euch nochmal im
drittel der hefe sparen oder die hälfte
drücken
wenn ihr fragen der vorteil davon
dann schmeckt einfach nicht nur
nachhilfe wobei mich das eigentlich nie
stört nämlich noch die restlichen abend
gefällt mir kommt noch
und jetzt plötzlich angst magneten und
leeren sessel gebe ich dann noch dazu
[Musik]
doch vier minuten kneten lassen
jetzt schauen wir nur noch klebrig ist
und bisschen mehr vertragen kann wird er
da noch ein bisschen was dazu geben
kommt einfach darauf an wie gut und
warmwasser verwendet
wenn wir wirklich entwicklung
hätte ich mir eine arbeitsfläche ein und
vornehmlich das über ihr könnt aber auch
zum beispiel olivenöl benutzen
wie kann ich ein bisschen einfach
addieren da gibt es den teig drauf
[Musik]
es ist schon richtig schöner zeigt und
sagt hier backpulver mittlerweile habe
muss ich den tag noch mal aussehen
lassen sondern kann ihnen wie gesagt
sofort weiter verwenden da nehme ich
jetzt etwa golfball ungefähren großer
golfball mit glück in kleiner da nehme
jetzt golfballgroße portionen und vorm
sechzehner kugel 48 in gleichmäßige
portionen und jetzt kommt der pass mit
dem werkzeug und zwar bis hier ein paar
schillerlocken förmchen
sie bestehen aus edelstahl und die kann
man benutzen um ebendiese hörnchen zu
machen wenn man sie nicht hat kann man
natürlich auch zwischen einzelnen
galaxien machen und zwar aus papier und
alufolie wobei ich dazu sagen hoch dafür
gesundheitlich und umwelttechnik vom
bisschen problematisch ist also wohl ihr
seid noch nicht so oft am besten gar
nicht weil sie einfach nicht so richtig
abgebaut werden kann und auch für die
gesundheit ist nicht wirklich gut aber
dennoch diese männchen machen wollten
wir ein stück papier sollte es zu einem
hörnchen und packe ich dann in alufolie
ein könnte dann auch mehrfach benutzen
sie wirklich empfehle diese weise nicht
sondern eher die edelstahl variante sind
diese spieler lecken und rettet sie auch
gut ein
jetzt nehme ich eine bike kogel und die
würde zu einem langen strang geformt und
es geht auch am besten auf der leicht
gefährdeten arbeitsfläche
[Musik]
den langen strang drücke ich dann und
zinslast und nämlich ein schüler wecken
und gleich sechs anderen bin
funktioniert von mir am besten von links
nach rechts
das lässt sich selbst viele links für
viele rädchen an und rolle dann mit der
linken hand nach rechts und die rechte
hand unterstützt indem sie das
[Musik]
die hand wer jetzt noch mit einem
verkehrten eiweiß bestritten und dann
mit sesam bestreut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und die werden jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 190 grad ober unsere
geschäft für etwa sechs sender france
inter baku golf eingeschätzt hier schon
mal die brote sind die habe ich ein
bisschen abkühlen lassen und da kann man
dann auch die form ganz gleich davon
lösen
jetzt habe ich hier im sommer den gibt's
auch schon auf meinem kanal und den habe
ich in einen spritzbeutel gefüllt denn
je nachdem was ihr daheim fühlt können
dass entweder einen löffel machen oder
ganz einfach mit dem schritt wollten
alle sind echt einfach eine paprika
väter creme zum beispiel wird auch geht
[Musik]
blöde kommentare als diese beurteilen
sind auf jeden fall richtig holen volles
fingerfood auch zum mitnehmen und ihr
könnt ihn tätig ist alles einzeln
gleichzeitig auch ein paar tolle idee
und dann schreiben sie uns in die
kommentare
franchise machen und die leute wieder
oberst zwei und langsam bergauf noch von
sport macht nichts
das rezept nachlesen will dann geht auch
tennis - glock der das jetzt noch mal
ganz genau und ich wünsche euch ernst
versprach danach machen wir noch einen
guten appetit und
doch die wissenschaftler wollen mit dem
einem auge besonders macht die kamera
aus der schweiz
[Musik]
[Applaus]